[Music]
in lighted up news
slide it up what are we smoking today
boys submitted by the Marlboro Man Oh
what happened to him huh they don't
advertise on Billboard's anymore Yeah
right he got killed by dual a college
course on tobacco allows students to
smoking class causing online controversy
if it's about the study doesn't that
make sense without what if it was
drinking in class yeah so this takes
place in China and there's this class
where they're studying about tobacco and
so they allowed the students I bet you
in China the study is how do you make it
more addictive to let it go sell more
yeah so it's part of the money no
problems agriculture University
sounds pretty communist to me viral on
Weibo yeah so everyone's smoking
everyone's so happy like that looks like
a child I know
oh that's college must be worse [ __ ]
blurring I've ever seen in my life
college students y'all what if you had
to smoke to get an A which I'll do it
[ __ ] yeah that's all I have to do I'll
smoke any P even more then oh damn but
yeah so a lot of people online are just
so upset they're like how could they
risk these students health their lives
maybe but there's their lives at risk
also they're not they're not smokers
already it's part of the class oh and so
the university did say like hey you know
this is optional it's not oh you don't
have to come to class during this day
where we're learning about this [ __ ] but
this is just another teaching method for
them to get to know the product like
tobacco that we're studying I was a
sensory evaluation and it's necessary so
they could professor is supposed to quit
cigarettes he keeps on getting in fights
with his wife and the only way that you
sneaking in is doing it to the class and
you watch the hot boxes you get
secondhand smoke you smell like
cigarettes tongue what do you mean he's
for the class it's
see I don't like it but it seems like
it's like a one-time thing and I think
if you tell kids like yeah you can smoke
see if you like it cuz nobody actually
really likes cigarettes like you know it
was kind of like a rebellion thing and
then you just kind of get addicted
me I don't see anything wrong with it
but I know I'm also weird and different
but I'm like it's just one cigarette and
if everyone can do it in a free
environment where you're not peer
pressure like you get to like it's an
experimental explorative space like do
was that weird why do I don't see
anything wrong with it because they're
college students yeah and it's not
mandatory so I don't see anything wrong
with it's just photos and I think a lot
of people get rolled up yeah because
they tie their own stories they have
their own little Jake a new session when
they see the picture they you know they
kind of tie their own like in-betweens
so when they see that it is kind of
graphic it's kind of like damned
cigarettes in the classroom that's weird
you know one and they look hella young
too so they were probably like oh my god
these junior high kids I'm scrolling
past I'm ever gonna read the article
yeah I thought you were gonna show me
toddlers oh [ __ ] no there are toddlers
smoking technology class it's a
cigarette technology Oh No
now would you like they're sampling
different ones well yeah which I don't
like
the teacher brought various brands of
cigarettes wait are they gonna learn how
to makeup I don't know how to sell them
but they're saying that they so the
teacher invited the students to try them
as a way to better understand tobacco
its flavors the irritation it causes to
a throat the aftertaste on the mouth and
the post come but combustion how amazing
it makes me feel yeah so they were not
required to smoke but most of them did
anyway yeah they're just saying I just
think it's weird done indoors yeah
because I felt like I was it give me a
headache cuz if kids wanted to opt out
of it they're still in that room
smelling it true or do they just not
show up that day I think it would have
been better if they took them to like a
tobacco factory and they had like a
little field trip and then at the end of
it they're like well you can try to get
to smoke it at the end I mean you can
also just make them read a book because
very often we learn things about them
and we don't have to injure them or try
them how
and we still person like me I have to
try I can't read about skydiving on how
to do it yes you can tell me as much as
you want and on my cool try to learn
from your mistakes but it's not until I
do it that it sticks do you want that do
you want the guy that works on your
parachute to actually skydive or just
read about skydiving and then he works
on the parachute
well then told ya you don't have to take
a secret technology people that are
taking cigarette technology class well
you're kidding colleges have free will
you know they'll be in that class go to
alcohol technology you get all the free
shots you want like this I'm gonna be
like I'm gonna be like one of those like
moms that seems cool but like I'm really
strict like and don't ask me to do
anything you know I mean like that's
gonna be my thing but then they're gonna
pull up all the [ __ ] Jake and use
videos that you did oh really mom what
about that and then they're gonna go to
the room and they won't have internet
for the rest of the week you don't want
these kids to do this know her own yeah
oh well that's your kids that's fine you
control them yes till you die until yeah
that's right I gotta say until they're
25 and I like I have Asian kids don't
friggin that'll work I think I'm
annoying to be addicted to something I
think it's so hated age it is [ __ ]
obnoxious just something small I don't
think I've ever been addicted to
anything other than [ __ ] candy but
even then this mm-hmm
well addicted to this and this is so
[ __ ] a noise speak for yourself David
I'm woke here's the thing with most most
addictions most addictions people don't
know that they're addicted yeah because
the first step to recognizing addiction
is you have to first admit that you are
buddy though you're addicted to Bart's
dick that's awesome that's awesome
that's why you had I'm addicted to
caffeine that's for sure oh you've seen
her [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I forgot that
romance Annette
[ __ ] for sure yeah welcome to our love
life yeah but like I was thinking the
other day when I was up when I was
laying down trying to go to sleep I had
to look at this thing you know still
[ __ ] obnoxious so how come I can't
just leave this alone or why can't I
leave this in the living room because I
had this charging in the living room
before I was watching Iron Chef America
the challenging thing yeah and then I
left it there and I went outside and
technically I don't need to have this
phone next to me
but I was sleeping laying in bed and
then I had to get up and bring my phone
next to me for what [ __ ] David
because what if somebody calls you in
the night and they're like a family
members dying and you don't answer it
and then you [ __ ] up this addiction
making excuses
that's your addiction making excuses
never happen I just don't need to be
next to it and I think I kind of felt a
little oh like weak gimme yeah but you
feel weak every time I need to take this
[ __ ] I got to get this first and I'm
like damn what happened to the old
school [ __ ] when you just sat there and
stead up the wall I know I call you out
on it all the time I know I'm addicted
to this up we're all they do this it's
much more fun when you read stuff while
you [ __ ] I know what you told me this
morning that you brought a magazine I
was like a magazine for what to read cuz
I knew I know you're like an hour early
so I got a magazine I want to stare at
my phone for an hour
you woke his [ __ ] thank you Dave maybe
your phone's like a smash at the pieces
right now
what if somebody calls me an interior
design magazine and I saw some
incredibly delightful things and have it
be the best woman that I can be you guys
do you guys have that feel more tells
you how many hours you're on your phone
well everyone has it with an apple this
I don't know if you have the new update
it just shows up mine says my says my
weekly phone time is three hours but
then average is actually two hours a day
for most people I think that this is
well I'm even though my work is online
I'm actually not on my phone that much I
mean that's why you're so successful
dude my average phone time he was
averaging about the four hours a day
four hours a day I know it just told me
so your settings what is yours
two hours but only like an hour on
social media yours just two hours a day
- three hours a week my [ __ ] wasn't on
social media though a lot of it was
was email and then the [ __ ] note a
because I'm always writing [ __ ] on it so
it's like maybe she's getting [ __ ]
laptop - 45 I don't know maybe cuz our
phones are on airplane mode but mine was
like three hours and all in it but it
said the average person for me it's an
hour and a half per day
it's my average for the last seven days
that's less than the average person
yeah and you work online the average
there's like two hours that's crazy but
damn instagrams the most used for most
people I think that's pretty mine's
messages see I think that the people
that like make all this technology
conspiracy bows is coming back so yeah I
think that you would think you know
unlike a basic level you would think
yeah they want you to get addicted and
use it as much as possible however they
know how fickle we are especially like
Millennials and like I think they know
like oh if they use it too much they'll
like start hating it and be like all I'm
on this too much on their own accord so
let's ah they can't even control this
control yeah I think that they I still
think they put out the times though
because Instagram did it - there is a
reasoning why they did it but it's cuz
they already know how we work so they
give us a baseline so we think oh as
long as we're not hating over this it's
fine but then hitting that numbers
actually too much still they know
something that we don't know about us
that's right sometimes I think before I
speak Bart yeah that's good that's good
that you're a brainstorm er yeah I'm
brainstorming that's trying to bounce
ideas off y'all you know I agree with
those ideas stop using your phone's
unless you're watching JK news I don't
know I like using my phone
I'm not addicted I refuse
[Music]